and we had certainly given
Ibrahim his sound judgment
before and we were of him well
knowing. What is meant by
before Yet certainly given
Ibrahim his sound judgment.
before. This word before
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did
not mention any particular time
attached to this before what?
It's open ended. and when
something is left open ended in
the Quran, it's done that way
for a reason. done that way in
order to be more general, more
inclusive
statement of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala before is meant two main
things. Number one, before
before he was a grown man,
while he was still a child,
before he grew up, For two,
before, meaning before other
main prophets and messengers
who came after him. Such as
Musa Alaihi Salam, Naisa,
Muhammad, before all of these
messengers,
was the messenger of Allah
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
and we were of him well knowing
When he said to his father and
his people. Ibrahim Alaihi
Salam referred to
is an Arabicized word from
Aramaic. What does that mean?
when a word is brought in from
another language.
and it is transferred onto a
different language. Usually,
that word is kept intact.
However, it will be given that
languages letters and it will
be given that language is based
on that language's scales,
right? So, there are many words
in the Quran which originate
from other languages. There are
many words in the Quran that
originate from other languages.
However, they are placed, they
are mentioned in the Quran,
with Arabic letters and Arabic
pronunciations So, for
instance, Ibrahim is not an
Arabic name. This is a name
which is taken from Aramaic.
Likewise, Asa is not an Arabic
name. No, it's not an Arabic
name. Ibrahim is hack. Jacob
These are not Arabic names.
Star, foreign names which have
been given Arabic, letters, and
Arabic pronunciations. and this
process is common to every
language. Every language in
which its people import and
export aspects of their
culture. This process will
happen. So, for instance, when
we come from overseas, in
English, when we import names
from Arabic, we give them
English letters and we give
them English pronunciations.
So, instead of saying,
Mohammed, we say, Mohammed.
Instead of saying, Ibrahim, we
say, Abraham, This is? Common.
And it happened in the opposite
way as well. Ibrahim is not an
Arabic name. It's an Arabic
Arabic name. Aramaic is the is
the language that Arabic is
originally derived from. those
original Semitic languages,
Hebrew, Arabic, they are
derived from Arabic. As a
matter of fact, the letters
the shape of the letters in the
Arabic language are taken from
Aramaic originally. And this is
why these shapes have very
strong ties to Aramaic culture.
Because the shapes of these
letters are taken from Aramaic.
and so Ibrahim is an Aramaic
name. It's been given Arabic
letters, Arabic pronunciation,
and the Quran as Ibrahim and
there are many different ways
to recite this. Ibrahim,
Ibrahim, etcetera. There are
few different ways. All of them
are correct recitations. And
the of this word Ibrahim is
actually
a composition of two words and
that is
the father of all. That is the
meaning of Ibrahim. Other
scholars mention a merciful
father. And this is a befitting
name for Ibrahim. Is Ibrahim
Alaihi Salam is known as the
father of the prophets. because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent
all prophets and messengers
after him from from his
lineage. All prophethood is in
the lineage of Ibrahim. All
revelation from Allah after
Ibrahim resides in the lineage
of Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. All
prophets and messengers after
Ibrahim come from Ismael and
Isaac. All prophets and
messengers come from
except for Ismael and Muhammad
They are the only two prophets
outside of that lineage.
Ibrahim
says to his father and his
people. course Ibrahim is from
from Alach originally.
and his people worshiped
celestial bodies. They were
very engrossed in
astrology We're very engrossed
in neurology and reading the
stars and worshiping these
celestial bodies as god's along
with Allah wa ta'ala. It didn't
believe that these things
created the heavens and the
earth necessarily It believed
that these things were to be
worshiped along with Allah as
saints or symbols of the
saints. Etcetera. And they did
as well believe that these
things articulated what the
future held for this world.
They believe that the stars and
the heavens manifest visually
what is held in the future for
this for this earth. And so
they would look into the stars
and they would try to read each
other's future and try to tell
what is going to happen. And
this is where the science of
astrology really comes from.
This is where? It sprouts from.
These beliefs. For this reason,
the prophet said,
Musnadil Imam Ahmed.
said
[Silence]
This is a denunciation of
learning astrology in any of
its forms. We're speaking not
just about worshiping or
looking into the future or also
white are referred to as
horoscopes horoscopes, you find
them in most newspapers and
most probably even have apps
now. newspapers and
magazines and so forth. Popular
culture Person will look at
their horoscope reading. See.
Have a good day. You're going
to have a good week. Month,
this is your year. It's always
positive things. It's never
anything terrible.
is a type of magic in the
general sense Which is referred
to in the Quran, in the diction
of the Quran. This is
considered to be a major sin in
Islam. Matter of fact, it's
considered to be a type of
shirk. Prophet said, Yeah.
Whoever goes to a soothsayer or
a fortune teller then Allah
will not accept this person's
salah for 40 days.
That's elsewhere
[Silence]
in what Allah has sent down to
[Arabic recitation]
very detrimental to a person's
religion They attend such
gatherings or read such
periodicals.
may just be fun. It's just for
fun. It's not With Allah, it is
a big deal. There is no fun to
be had and issues of religion
and issues of the worship of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
the names and attributes of
Allah. These are not issues to
play and poke fun at. Look,
this is a type of cohort. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
[Silence]
Allah or his signs or verses or
his messenger
[Silence]
and his people. We will
continue this narrative
tomorrow inshallah.